怎麼辦 今天台灣股市雖然上漲
但是量能急縮
你有沒有看到 漲77點
Lucky 7嗎
台灣股市到底怎麼辦
是不是大家不相信這個行情
會上48000 會上5萬點呢
第二個 最新的八卦
我告訴大家
我昨天光是熬夜看這些論文
看這些研究
我看得頭好痛
因為這不是我本科系的
但如果你是本科系 你會很興奮
AI算完90億種
比人類的數量還多
90億種DNA變化
疾病將全面攻克
哲哲之前有講過
我等一下給你看我的預告
現在已經有人預言跟我講一樣的事情
第三個 凌晨1點的蘋果發表會
是台股利多嗎
AI救不了台股
是不是摺疊手機救得了台股
大家好 我是摩爾投顧投資長
郭哲榮分析師
也是全台灣唯一一位百萬粉絲訂閱
甚至140萬粉絲訂閱的分析師
來 今天台灣股市上漲77點
我現在快要變成AI說明大會了
可是我跟你講
我越看我越興奮
我跟你講一件事
我直接給你結論好不好
我不是說3到5年內嗎
助理給我那張圖就是
按照台股的報酬
什麼時候會到10萬點
我說5年嗎
沒有 我要改變我的說法
聽清楚 我再給你結論
3年內就會10萬點了
再講一次 3年內就會10萬點
我不會說百分之百
因為我是合格的分析師
可是我告訴你 我認為機率很大
再講一次 3年內台股10萬點
我不要一堆分析師講什麼點數
5萬點 6萬點 7萬點
我喊的數字很大就算了
我告訴你時間軸
3年內10萬點 進步太快了
越來越符合我說的這句話
你們看清楚
我說AI真的發展起來的時候
你們都有印象 我怎麼說
我說一般
以前複合成長率10% 20%算很厲害
AI真的起來的時候他是這樣子
90度 接近90度的成長
因為AI可以再研發AI
AI不用休息
投資朋友 你去想一件事情
我告訴大家
等一下蘋果摺疊手機
我先解大盤
不然你們都覺得我不認真
其實我從頭到尾在解盤
只是有些人很奇怪
一定要按照他的邏輯解大盤
這個股票漲 這個鴻海 台積電
我是先解大盤再跟你講
我就喜歡畫夢給你看
來 我們先來看一下
大盤這個基本上不用看了
台灣50是不是賺1800萬 1900萬
I don't care
你只要記得
在這邊的時候誰叫你買的
去年26000的時候
誰喊36000 誰喊4萬點
我們的粉絲都可以見證
我有故意誇大其詞
應該說故意造假啦
下台一鞠躬
來 在這邊的時候4萬點
這不到1個半月的事情
39384點那一天
我破了以後 我買台灣50
賺了快1800萬
沒關係 繼續放著
賺了快1800萬到今天
昨天突破了47578點
快要突破前高了 前高是多少
48218點 指日可待
真的指日可待
我們來告訴大家
所以你說為什麼很多股票
譬如國巨為什麼沒漲
有時候你們要有耐心好不好
遲早會缺的 好不好
環球晶呢 遲早會缺的
我昨天有沒有說3532台勝科
考慮再買一下
你看台勝科都噴出去了
因為台勝科籌碼比較乾淨
矽晶圓會缺更快 好不好
矽晶圓我認為明年就會全面缺貨了
Wait and see
我們來看一下這個東西
助理有沒有找到那個預告
請助理找預告
你們來看這些東西 來
你們看了會起雞皮疙瘩
Arm執行長有沒有看到
他是全世界晶片的設計
他都收專利權
全世界大部分晶片
都要付給Arm OK嗎
IP矽智財這一塊
AI將找到癌症解方有沒有看到
能力會變得更強大
但晶片短缺會阻礙發展進度
是不是跟我講的一模一樣
為什麼 因為他可以強大的算力
去模擬細胞 人體 DNA標記
Arm執行長講的話
你要記得一件事
代表他是認真的
剛好無奇不有
今天又發生一個我剛才說的
90億種的DNA變化也破解了
他需要算力
因為他有時候算DNA的變化90億種
那你算完出來以後 你還要再算
哪一種藥適合他
他的需求很大
但是瓶頸 平井堅
這個應該年輕人
不知道我在講什麼東西
你會唱平井堅的歌嗎 不會
他的歌很高
來 AI發展算力需求
那你供給就是少啊
那以後還可以人形機器人以勞動轉型
慢慢跟大家講
你來看一下
如果你喜歡看
Google AI最新發展
看我的節目就好了
你要每天漲停板
我跟你講
有些老投顧 詐騙集團
每天都給你漲停板
不要講詐騙集團
這樣講很過分
都胡扯 好不好
或者是天天追漲停
我不會講是誰
我沒有要阻礙人家賺錢
我只是跟你講
你要每天看每天賺錢的
然後反而不敢參加選股比賽的
別家投顧很多有
我只能做摩爾投顧的品質保證
不好意思
我喜歡當預言家
我不喜歡只當分析師 很無聊
你要當分析師很簡單
來 帆宣怎麼樣
有沒有 精材啦 賺150%
今天又再拉了
連續4天上漲有沒有
然後帆宣今天快漲停板了 6%
又賺50%
我可以講20分鐘 好無聊
這不是我要做的事情好不好
我喜歡當預言家
我剛才已經講得很清楚
來 3年內10萬點
把我的話記起來 好不好
3年10萬點 我認真的
你們對3年10萬點有沒有什麼感覺
換句話說其實你們現在光台灣50
3年內你就可以翻一倍了
這個跟大家講
哲哲是財閥家的小兒子
你是說那個回到過去是不是
回到過去對不對
你有沒有覺得很恐怖
我連這個都看
我沒有看 我只是喜歡看大概而已
OK嗎 來
來 平井堅
3年10萬點記得這件事好不好
哲哲一定是未來人
一定跟你講好不好
哲哲要3點了 什麼意思
先來跟大家講 來看一下
你們對3年10萬點這麼相信我
大家都沒什麼想法是不是
來啦 今天無奇不有 你看到
Arm執行長大膽預言
今天我先跟你講一件事
我先慢慢跟大家講說
他已經說AI可以攻克癌症
有機會了對不對
只是算力需求很大
但是晶片廠商
AI伺服器生產太慢了
所以你們不要再說AI泡沫了好不好
這是第一個
第二個Google DeepMind
我先講大綱
預測90億種DNA變異
他已經把人體的秘密
都基本上破解完了
很誇張 好
這是其中一個
還有一個
Google AI模型
颶風預報 就是颱風
一躍就超過10年的變化
一天就10年的變化
就是領先10年
多一天防災預警
多一天差很多
颱風天多一天差很多
還有一個
我這個來不及做AI圖
做太多了 做到頭痛了
我們每個
一會我要化身為氣象專家任立渝
一會我要化身為DNA專家 醫學專家
還要懂變異
然後還有一個
100年的現在討論了
懸賞100萬的數學難題
也被OpenAI破解了
另外一個數學家說他剽竊
反正吵來吵去都是用AI
恐不恐怖
都在一天之內發生這麼大的新聞
你還不懂AI發展很恐怖嗎
我說3年10萬點
我還是客氣了
我預測大盤是很準的
3年10萬點 記得這件事
我郭哲榮沒有任何媒體
從1個粉絲到現在100多萬
靠的是自己 靠的是預測能力
有很多人討厭我 我不在乎
我看的是 因為我看到未來
大家喜歡看準的預測
就來看我的節目
就這麼簡單而已 好不好
我講這些 跟你講細節好不好
我就講恐怖
來 我們講一個東西
90億種DNA
來 我也是很認真練習
蛋白質有大概2%
有編碼區的 蛋白質編碼區
這2%
可以搞定很多事情
有很多疾病可以那個
有救了
可是2% 之前只有2%
我先跟你講
之前2%
DeepMind Google的公司
DeepMind發現了
破解這2%的蛋白質編碼區 DNA
那是2%
你們常常看到這種DNA的圖片有沒有
還有98%沒有破解
那我再講一次
破解這2%的蛋白質編碼區
就DNA裡面有2%蛋白質編碼區
聽不懂沒關係 大概懂就好
有98%非編碼的DNA
反正他以前破解的2%
就得了諾貝爾是什麼獎
助理幫我查一下
就得了諾貝爾獎
不知道化學獎還是醫學獎
幫我查一下
DeepMind 2%蛋白質編碼區
這樣搜尋就好
然後諾貝爾獎
導播你幫我搜尋
按照我這個 什麼
化學獎 諾貝爾化學獎
所以醫學最後的方程式
是化學方程式而已
2%破解
才2%破解就已經可以得了
諾貝爾化學獎
2%耶
現在一口氣98%
49倍
你跟我說AI進展快不快
是不是我說的垂直90度發展
幾乎垂直90度發展
2%就多厲害的事情
這才幾年前的事情
現在98%一下破解
破解完以後
我跟你講
我有想過我要跟你解釋這些東西
什麼基因是有31個DNA字母
什麼ATCG
換掉一個字母就有一個選擇
你懂我的意思嗎 換掉
那個我怕你們聽不懂 不用啦
它就是一個
就是反正就是
31個位置3種替換就90億種
你們懂嗎
不懂很正常 這不是重點
重點是以前2%破解了就
史上最偉大的發明
現在一口氣破解98%
然後90億種的變換
你知不知道
對RNA剪接等分子過程
那你要先了解 你要破解疾病
你要先了解DNA
怎麼變化嘛
你不了解它怎麼辦
所以現在開始了解了
一口氣破解
所以今天才有這個新聞
Arm執行長說AI找到癌症解方有沒有
這是Arm講的
來看一下我預測未來
來 這是什麼時候
5月8號 天啊
4個月前的時候 4個月前
還沒有破解這90億種
它超乎你想像的進步 你懂嗎
4個月前我說的
看一下我的預告
超乎你想像的進步 你懂嗎
現在已經到一個AI的世界
你們現在要做的是趕快做健康檢查
度過這10年
超過10年後基本上
很多人會長命百歲
因為基本上癌症
癌症就是一個機率而已
就是你細胞一直在分裂
你問很多醫生你知道
就是運氣不好
剛好分裂到壞的細胞
剛好分裂到癌症細胞
可是以後你的癌症
你可以對症下藥
你用AI去解這些 你懂嗎
所以你要撐過
因為AI訓練很快
這10年趕快
這10年怎麼樣讓自己不要得癌症
多賺點錢 多睡點覺
多花點錢 賺錢要記得花
你有沒有覺得很恐怖
我是預言家
有些人 同業或怎麼樣
或一些網友小鼻子
有些同業小鼻子 小眼睛
我不在乎 我是預言家
我是從內心告訴你
怎麼樣讓你人生更快樂
先賺錢 賺錢以後要先有健康
10年後癌症都攻克了
看起來是很有機會
Arm執行長也跟你講
Arm很有名好不好 Arm
很多晶片設計
很多晶片公司都要付錢給他
他光靠晶片設計躺著賺錢就好了
投資朋友 那今天也跟你講
90億種DNA
98%的非蛋白質的編碼區 DNA
又破解了
就可以2%破解了就可以得諾貝爾獎
這多偉大的發明 98%
然後又有什麼颱風
又可以領先預報
還有什麼100萬的數學破解了
代表這個難題很難
人家拿出100萬來
這都是這幾天的事情
我再跟你講更恐怖的
我們不是說Astra嗎
有人叫Astra嘛
就是我說這是AGI很恐怖
就是他有一般人工智慧
我知道你們一直聽不懂
這跟Agent有什麼差別
或者是跟那個
我跟一般的AI有什麼差別
他可以玩世紀帝國2
他可以跟你一起玩很多遊戲
他就是你一個隱形的助理
不只是隱形的助理
Agent是助理而已
他是你隱形的夥伴 甚至比你強
我再舉一個更恐怖
為什麼AGI
還有AGI的產生都很恐怖
我這樣跟你講好了
我用AGI怎麼樣
譬如說這是我在剪片對不對
這個導播應該有看過
這是Premiere對不對 是 沒錯
這是音軌有沒有
幾分幾秒有沒有看到
這裡有什麼字幕
這是圖片剪輯
還有加入音檔對不對
這是圖片剪輯有沒有
這是字幕 圖片 加入音檔
這些對不對
那Premiere是這樣子
以前是不是我們自己剪片
你以前剪片 幾年前要剪片
像這種真的認真剪片
我們這個不算剪片
我們只有圖跟效果而已
做特效怎麼樣是不是
剪個片 剪個一兩天很正常
剪一兩天算快的 對不對
剪片這是Premiere
那以後說我們剪片
是不是可以教AI軟體
對 你教AI軟體
只能跟你講一個大概
我要這個畫面要鮮明一點
可是這個敘述有時候很不清楚
AGI怎麼樣
你以後用AGI就好了
AGI跟一般的AI軟體不一樣
我要剪片 我要剪郭哲榮爆笑的短片
然後跳舞啊 震胸舞啊 特效啊
以前用Premiere做你會非常痛苦
要找非常多元素
那現在有AI軟體 OK
可是你有時候就覺得怪怪的
這不是我要的角度
這不是我要的臉
這個細節我沒辦法雕
沒錯吧 導播這細節我沒辦法雕
導播沒錯吧 沒錯
我講這個是講給你們聽的
細節沒辦法雕嘛
這個臉看起來不像郭哲榮
那怎麼雕
AI軟體反正它生成就生成對不對
你只能下個指令
看起來鮮明一點
看起來更像郭哲榮一點
就是不像郭哲榮怎麼辦
AGI最恐怖是什麼 來
他就進去這個軟體了
你就看到有滑鼠在運動
那個是AGI 那是AI
他幫你剪片 剪片 剪片
剪到一半你說這不像我
他就停止了
你可以叫他停止
他就像一個人 旁邊有助理
他就像導播一樣
我可以唸他 你懂不懂
你幹什麼 你不能剪片這個東西嘛
為什麼 重新寫報告
他就會寫報告 然後改正
那你剪完以後對不對
好 假設從頭到尾你最後結束了
你是不是可以自己再插入影片
你是不是可以自己再插入效果
你以前一般的AI軟體
做那種AI影片
很難做
因為你要敘述得好
可是現在不是 他就是在這邊
剪片軟體裡面他直接做給你看
遊戲軟體他直接下給你看
你可以叫他暫停
這很恐怖吧
所以這就是AGI很恐怖
所以我一直在想我怎麼舉一個例子
你以前用AI剪片好像很厲害
可是他只是一個敘述而已
他不是 他現在是在這邊
你可以隨時叫他暫停
你也可以叫他做完以後
你自己再加一些元素 加一些原料
加一些聲音 加一些音檔
這樣做事情很方便
所以不只剪片這個行業設計
設計師也是這個行業
做3D模組的
他是一個非常龐大的商業模式
所以又怎麼樣
一年投資1兆美金又怎麼樣
你們看不到未來啊
很恐怖啊
你要把我今天這一段影片
真正看十遍啊 我跟你說真的
你沒有看三遍對不起你自己
你就知道為什麼看三遍以後
你就知道為什麼台灣股市上10萬點了
我給你舉一個很簡單的例子
你一定要聽得懂
聽不懂我沒辦法
像導播你現在聽得懂吧 是
問你比較清楚啊
導播滿聰明的
導播完全懂了吧 懂
你是在昨天之前
比較不懂AGI嘛
還是大概懂 大概懂
現在講有比較清楚了吧 有
很恐怖對不對 很恐怖
那是不是可以取代很多人力
導播你這樣懂嗎 懂
所以你們都很危險喔 是
加油啦 加油啦
我舉這個例子很恐怖
這就是AGI啊
AGI產生這幾天
然後DNA破解這幾天
然後颱風提前預報領先10年
然後癌症又有人預期 癌症要破解了
3年10萬點
AGI這個是很恐怖
我很開心
我一直在想我要舉什麼例子
我怕你們聽不懂
它很恐怖 OK嗎
聽得懂嗎 聽得懂回應我一下好不好
因為沒有分析師跟你講這些東西
好不好
哲哲以前拍的那些科幻電影慢慢實現
機器人也是有可能啊
你各位被取代了 OK嗎
鏟子已經賣到供不應求了
有沒有懂 請拍桌子
懂了喔 懂了喔
有點像Agent
比Agent更厲害了
因為Agent
比Agent更厲害了好不好 對啊
AI打不過FAKER
你要看什麼時候的AI
遲早會打贏的好不好
哪有打不過啊
馬斯克那時候還跟他說要調整速度
你可以滑
電腦就可以調那個滑的速度啊 好不好
馬斯克好像要跟他
要跟他比賽人腦
就人腦跟電腦的差別
他們也沒比啊 印象中沒比不是嗎
他還限制速度喔
如果沒限制速度根本就打不贏啊
人類根本打不贏AI
滑的速度 手的速度啊
你懂不懂 電腦如果速度很快的話
一般人怎麼贏 FAKER怎麼贏
FAKER就是一個非常有名的電競選手
我講的都是事實
其他分析師收一收了
不要這樣講
哲哲最強 講有的
我都預告在前面
我跟你講說可以破解好不好
完了
你說很多人要活到150歲
你不要這樣想嘛
我不講政治
AI失去工作的人越多
有可能啊
但有可能以後有新的AI工作
你懂我的意思嗎
哲哲很厲害
有用AI的人都懂
你們要懂我在說什麼好不好 OK
很專業 謝謝大家
所以你們要把我這段聽起來
那我跟你講
我大概只是舉個例子
我剪影片也好 建模也好
工程設計師也好
室內設計師也好
語音助理也好
客服電話人員也好
這些人都很快失業
哲哲怎麼現在沒失業
第一個 不是每個老闆
像哲哲動頭腦動那麼快
這沒辦法
可是第二個是
你到你要用的時候
你中間還有一個AI代理商
可能幫他
深入的幫每一家公司不一樣的問題
你還是有一點小小的規則
你能做 假設你能做客服助理
AI的客服助理
那你還是有一兩個問題你要解決
比如說有些人
問一些極端的問題怎麼辦
或者是我這家公司
我要針對什麼
這都要去調教的
我希望是怎麼樣的客服人員
比較卑微的 比較怎麼樣
然後所有的問題要問好
這一定要都Re好幾百次
可是時間快了
你們剩下時間不多了
你們要轉行的時間不多了
記住這句話
最好轉行的方式是先投資AI
好不好 OK嗎
每天都跟AI對話
不錯啦 感情的事不要跟AI對話啦
因為AI沒給你真正的
因為他們畢竟不懂感情
很多女生喜歡問AI感情的事情
男生跟女生不太一樣
聽哲哲講的以後我們就長命百歲
多賺錢就好
所以多賺錢啊 好不好
好 那你來看一下這個東西
那剛才講的就是這些
那還有一個東西
美國財長貝森特警告
中美AI競賽攸關國家存亡
他直接講
如果中國在AI競賽中勝出
明天過後都不會存在
他講得很清楚 他說什麼
這也是我用AI圖做的 你看多漂亮
我現在很多都不叫他們做了
是不是 像助理他不一定有美感啊
他不一定會畫圖啊
可是很多我也都請他幫我協助
你看做得很漂亮啊 是不是
為什麼這樣講 他講得很清楚
等一下喔
他講中國如果在AI領域
把我們甩在後面
那麼其他一切都白搭 為什麼
因為只要AI贏 全部都贏
我武器可以一起打
他們現在打是這樣打
一口氣設定100個地方
怎麼贏
那AI越強大
那問你一件事
你以後一定是AI對AI
這個AI能制服另外一個AI
他連武器都發不出來
所以美國很了解
如果我輸了中國
其他贏都沒有用
土地贏沒有用 人口贏沒有用
機器贏沒有用
我的AI可以制服你的AI
那我請問你一件事情
他們會不會投資AI
中國也知道這件事情 蘇聯也知道
俄羅斯也知道這件事情
美國也知道這件事情
光他們投資AI就要花多少錢了
怎麼樣都有國家挺
還有各個企業要投資AI
你們怎麼可以小鼻子小眼睛
7500億美金 四大CSP業者
看那些半瓶水的分析師
國外的分析師或本土分析師一起喊
這個AI是泡沫
他們也不敢講
他們看我的節目覺得AI是真的
可是他們舉不出所以然
我告訴你 你告訴我
哪個分析師可以像我
舉這些這麼具體的東西
我也跟你講說醫學常識啊
我就希望你身體健康 你懂不懂
甚至有時候賺錢擺在其次
我希望你身體健康 你才有錢賺啊
你活得久才有錢賺
織田信長 德川家康 豐臣秀吉
為什麼德川家康贏到最後
活得比較久嘛 是不是
豐臣秀吉就是亂搞
有人說他好像得了那個淋病
最近這個話題好像滿興盛的
算了 扯遠了
好啦 不要扯到別人
就是這樣 健康最重要 懂不懂
很多人得天下為什麼 健康最重要
歷史都是留給活的人寫 知道嗎
好啦 這扯遠了
你們不一定要當皇帝
可是你們要長命百歲 好不好
希望你們聽到我講的
如果我講那麼清楚
真的沒有人會跟你講這些
那麼清楚的東西
所以你每天要懂AI的故事
告訴我說
而且這些都是一兩天內又發生的
你覺得AGI
假設我現在AGI
就算不能贏FAKER 不能贏那些人
那你覺得下一代AGI會不會贏
再下一代AGI會不會贏
那你覺得下一代AGI會多久
我跟你講好不好
我認為只要1 2個月
就會有下一代AGI了
昨天還說那個圍棋
圍棋冠軍 世界冠軍 贏人家
導播你有沒有聽到這個新聞
你有看到 贏人家 贏電腦
讓兩子 讓兩個子
人家讓你先兩次
先下棋兩次 講錯話
這叫讓兩子 這樣叫做贏了
那個沒叫贏
我跟你講差距只是越拉越大
我跟你講 再講一次
下一代AGI
我認為3個月內就會產生了
最晚3個月內
記住我的預言
如果真的話 你再想想看我講的話
你要不要忍一下3年10萬點
所以你現在被套牢 我講最難聽的
但是不可能等到3年
1年內基本上通通有機會解套
你不要選爛股票就好
國巨你有什麼好怕
籌碼爛而已 沒關係 我不在乎
你覺得籌碼爛 你就買華新科
你看華新科幾天紅K了
你們不要開玩笑了好不好
華新科你看都已經破前高了
真的啦 要聽懂我看到的未來
我再講一次 AGI也是一樣
就是通用人工智慧也好
那100萬的數學難題
懸賞100萬也這幾天破解
90億的DNA組合
原本只有2%被破解 DNA組合
現在另外98%
不好意思 你原本破解2%
就可以得諾貝爾獎
多厲害的發明
現在98%都破解了
以後只會進展越來越快
破解以後是不是還要怎麼樣
記不記得我下一個預告
我問你一件事情
美國政府都會大力發展AI
中國不會嗎
第二件事情 光是各個政府發展AI
那些廠商錢就賺不完了
第二件事情 如果是巴菲特
巴菲特身家1000億 2000億 1兆
如果他不捐錢的話都好幾兆
身家1兆以上
巴菲特跟你換身體要不要
當然不要
他隨時要Byebye 90幾歲
沒有錯 所以巴菲特最渴望的
現在不是錢 是身體
那巴菲特如果你叫他
你跟他說你可以長命百歲
你要不要研發AI
他願不願意捐錢 他願不願意投資
一定投資
某種方面他投資Google
不就是這種嗎
我問你 你要不要跟巴菲特換身體
然後也順便換財產
這麼有錢為什麼不換
所以這些有錢人一定會砸錢在AI上面
不要跟我說AI是泡沫
講那些都是胡扯
只是他們現在還是看不到
股票市場很好玩
他現在還是有點保守
看不到真正的獲利 還在怕
很快就會有了 好不好
先發展再說
因為這個AI太快了
他不像網路一樣 你知道嗎
網路是慢慢發明 你知不知道
你的網路發明
2000年網路泡沫嘛
然後YouTube 是2006還2007年
真的YouTube多的是什麼時候
有4G
因為那時候我看NBA轉播比賽
我看YouTube就轉台 太慢了
可是現在4G以後 也不用管5G
到4G就是甜蜜點
可是AI的進步是無遠弗屆 他很快
他不需要等5 6年
所以不會有泡沫
網路的時候泡沫
是因為變現率很慢
因為畢竟是網路時代
AI他可以一直不休息
再講一次
最恐怖的是AI的進步是這樣進步
你們一定要記住我這句話
所以他很快就可以變現
大家也賭他很快會變現
下一代AGI太快會出現
再下一代太快會出現
接下來的速度會超乎你們想像
你們很幸福 也很悲哀
悲哀的是不懂AI的人
他就會一直被淘汰
不懂為什麼 怎麼會這樣 是不是
那悲哀是什麼 悲哀還有另外一種
你得癌症了
可是你沒有錢 是不是
你看沈玉琳
你不是說一個月要2 30萬嗎
可是他以前那個血癌是救不了的
新的醫療技術就是這麼快
以後我就跟你講
癌症可以針對你的腫瘤
針對你個性化
你個人化的腫瘤去打疫苗
那個疫苗是救你的癌症
針對你 只要是針對你個人的
量身定做的那是不是很貴
所以要賺點錢
不賺點錢醫藥費繳不起
我不是說各位要生病
我是說你們準備這種東西
去買一個保單
比買保單實際100萬倍
我都不懂你們為什麼要買保單
基本上我沒在買
所以我這樣講
有些人業務的同仁會很生氣
可是壽險業的
壽險相關的我會買
可是其他的我覺得買了沒什麼意思
你幹嘛 生病了給你錢要幹嘛
你為什麼不先賺多一點錢
買個100萬的保單
你說不定股票就可以賺到1000萬
我講的都是實話
雖然會得罪很多人
不過保險業務員還是需要他們存在
我也愛他們
扯遠了
所以華新科這些
到時候被動元件都會缺
都會被AI大黑洞吸走
東西都會漲價 漲多少而已
華新科都有機會再創新高
3年10萬點你覺得華新科不會喔
最晚就3年
我認為不會那麼久
講3年10萬點你們都沒有
導播他們剛才沒有很興奮嗎
我剛才沒看他們對話
有 還是有
你就知道我有幾分就講幾分話的人
我預測大盤很準 好不好 來
你的掉髮還有救嗎
我也想要知道白頭髮有沒有救
這個我會查 有我再跟你講
我趕快跟我自己講不要亂生氣
因為有人說白頭髮是不可逆的
AI可以救禿頭嗎
不用了 你們現在就吃那個就可以救了
雄性禿其實可以吃那個叫什麼
髮利明
不是啦 什麼髮利明
攝護腺的 那叫什麼
你連AI都不問禿頭怎麼救
你不要問我 我不理你
現在就有一些禿頭藥可以救的
我身邊很多人吃那個
我推薦他們去吃
頭髮都長出來了
打一下禿頭 攝護腺腫大
就搜尋出來了
導播搜尋出來沒
我們看一下夜盤
夜盤漲71點 不叫噴出啦
適尿通 不是那個啦
不要吃那個啦
有適尿通耶
不是啊 那我搞錯了是不是
一個叫什麼我忘記了
他是有這個功能的東西
投資長你講對了
柔沛啦 對 菲那雄胺
我們變成保健 我賣藥的是不是
地下電台 來 你來買這個藥
柔沛 配南瓜子
頭髮長出來了 現在Call in來
我不是賣藥的 跟你開玩笑
你這個不用問AI好不好
波斯卡 對 波斯卡比較便宜
學名藥有些比較便宜
不一定要買柔沛
威而鋼 好 夠了
我不是賣藥的好不好
黑到發亮的頭髮 就像我一樣
多替別人想就OK了 好不好
真的啦 有時候你們開心 我比較開心
比我賺錢開心
哲哲 你不要每天幫我算
我1億賺1900萬
好像賺1900萬了吧 昨天
那又怎麼樣 我沒有很開心
我又沒在花
有花錢啦
但是我真的就是沒有花很凶
我最開心的是花時間在你們身上 真的
所以這個被動元件用力買好不好
現在開始講股票
剛才講很多 你要想想看那些東西
記得再提醒我講蘋果 晚上的蘋果
來 被動元件要解套找我
你不找我沒辦法
尤其你高檔被套牢的人
你逢低一定要加碼
你不找我沒辦法
來 我跟他握個手
很詭異是不是
被動元件要解套要找我
你看做的字卡多好 多立體
不覺得我們都會做嗎
很多人說懂飆股
你要聽別人講
我們不用講AI
我只要漲停板就好
你相信喔 你相信喔
有些人都胡扯這些東西
你相信 你被騙剛好
不懂AI 然後跟你講AI股票
他的股票很賺錢 你相信嗎
被騙剛好 你被騙剛好
化被動為主動
主動88專案
好不好 這禮拜就一定要截止
最晚禮拜五 原則上是禮拜五截止
OK嗎 這個跟大家講
教誰 教別人做股票
我不教別人
不論是名嘴還是分析師
我不要去攻擊人家
哲哲會換iPhone 18嗎 會
我們先講我們的股票
我們來看一下我們剛才念的簡訊
來 我們看一下我們今天股票
3374有沒有看到
精材有沒有看到
連續漲4天
之前連續漲6天以後 7天
再連續漲4天 飛到天際
我是不是說過 我有沒有預告
我說創新高後 勢不可擋
我還說先600再說
很誇張 現在已經快500了
前陣子才277 有沒有看到
現在已經快500了
所以這個精材的恭賀簡訊
當然很精彩
我們請我們最美麗的 來
希望各位真的聽懂我看到的未來
你不覺得AI進步很快嗎
你還不覺得你很危險嗎
沒有關係 你只要是我的粉絲 我罩你
會員啦 粉絲我也幫你
但是重點是要罩會員
我最愛的是會員 不好意思
我最愛的一定是會員 一定不是粉絲
但是我也愛粉絲
但是我最愛的是會員
來 我們會員的簡訊來念一下
好 9月9號禮拜三 今天的簡訊
恭喜3374精材
股價已經連4漲 再創歷史新高
我們買進到現在
最高已經大賺150% 財富翻倍
我持續看好它
手上持股獲利續抱
恭喜大家賺大錢啦
以前 其實很多人你會發現到
我詢問很多人就是說
現在根本不知道需求是多少
來啦 數學界的也需要AI
然後DNA界 醫學界 各種藥
幾百 幾萬種病都可以破解
然後幾百萬種工作流程
幾萬種 幾百萬種的工作
很多都可以被取代
所以你們會覺得AI是泡沫
現在最怕是入不敷出
投資AI沒有回報
可是不是啊 AI運用面太大了
就我剛講的AGI
你可以叫它做任何事情
所以AGI很恐怖
你可以叫它去打世紀帝國
你叫它打遊戲 叫它剪影片
叫它建模組 叫它寫報告
它就是一個人 而且是全能的人
素質滿 又服從你
又不會跟你吵架
然後任何事情它都會做
它可以從無中生有
不用懂這個規則 他看一看就懂了
智商比你高
所以它跟那種
2000年的網路泡沫不一樣
我基礎建設建很多
不一樣啊
現在基礎建設資源太多
也沒有用 也不夠用
因為AI發展速度太快了
我就說 下一代AGI
記得3個月內就一個版本
下一代AGI 3個月內
再怎麼不濟 你相信我
Google一定會有個AGI
3個月內
我認為ChatGPT就有下一個版本
最差 最差
別家公司有另外一種版本的AGI
那你會覺得會不會發展很快
所以這些
台積電資本支出概念股為什麼噴
最需要 因為瓶頸就在台積電
晶片 還有記憶體
所以記憶體不會死 頂多上不去而已
它的缺貨不是像疫情一樣
兩年 三年 一兩年而已 懂嗎
不像航運股現在漲一下
我今年就是 2603
長榮有沒有看到 是不是漲一下而已
是不是 漲一波
我是不是說主力拉抬就漲一波而已
因為業界的人 我剛好
誰叫我當分析師當了20年
都知道萬聖節 聖誕節
還有什麼
萬聖節 聖誕節
忘記了還有什麼 感恩節啦
10月 11月 12月
外國人都過這些節 你懂嗎
外國人都過這些節 然後呢
所以8月份就會開始拉貨了 不然來不及
不然怎麼10月份送到貨
所以8月份拉起來
為什麼只做這一波
因為後面運價就會下去了
可是現在不一樣
我們現在一直缺AI 一直缺AI
我講各行各業到時候都需要
你要懂我看到的未來 OK嗎
來 參加會員很貴嗎
你自己打電話
來電洽詢0800668085
哲哲不是賣藥的
你問會費就問一下服務人員 好不好
哲哲剪頭髮了
我常常剪 好不好 來
智原沒有在高頂上
智原其實一直不高
所以反彈很正常
可是問題是
他最大缺點是 對不起
最大的缺點是
他那個AI的需求
現在還沒有擴張到那邊去
ASIC他還沒賺到
那遲早都會有 OK嗎
現在連國科會
某些整合計畫有沒有看到
生物醫學的
也規定必須融合AI去分析
或建立Marker推測疾病
你不講還好
你知道AGI還有一個東西
大家說機器人可不可以
我是不是去年的時候
我說機器人沒有那麼快
我還是低估了AI的發展速度
來看一下這個最新新聞
你看到這可以識別 這是AI
它可以知道這是什麼東西
櫃子裡面什麼東西
籃子裡面什麼東西
什麼人啊 什麼東西
它可以知道每個機器的不同
那識別有什麼好處
我以後不用看人工監視器
我不用人監控
我直接機器監測
你的AI 另外一個AI
放東西的機器人或人
把這個東西放在籃子裡面有沒有
這東西沒有放在這個籃子
就會警告聲響 它可以辨別
踢足球比賽也可以 它可以辨別
那是不是已經有機器人的眼睛了
有機器人的腦袋了
機器人的腦袋是怎麼樣
機器人腦袋是
不好意思 我只是訂餐機器人
餐廳機器人 其他我都不會
那哪叫做AI
它就像你在電影裡面看到的AI
你可以跟它談心 你可以跟它聊天
你現在已經跟它聊天了
你可以跟它玩世紀帝國
它真的可以玩了
它現在看得懂你在講什麼
看得懂你的動作了
它可以辨別 它可以掛標籤
這已經很恐怖了
機器人已經呼之欲出了
我以前說機器人不會那麼快
我還是低估AI的發展
連我這麼樂觀的人
所以我說3年10萬點
根本是送錢給你們
可是我跟你們講3年10萬點
股市是股市
它到最後還是會泡沫
一定會過度投資 但不是現在
它會過度投資 台股會泡沫
但是絕對不是現在
我認為不是現在
我不要說絕對兩個字
我們是合法分析師 不好意思
不像其他網紅
現在最好笑的是
我們還被網紅攻擊
有本事就考分析師
真的 有本事就考分析師
我們講的每一句話我們都要被監督
OK嘛 是不是 我講的是事實
我們都不能偷做股票 是不是
我就光明正大買ETF而已
就這樣子而已
好啦 那扯遠了
我剛才講什麼
在這個機器人會產生
你要能識別這個東西
進展太快
連我這麼樂觀的人
都比我想像中進展快
有些人跟你每天講飆股
連AI是什麼都不知道
你看我的節目就覺得
哲哲為什麼講那麼多
因為我現在跟你講的是
我也不想最近講AI
是最近進展太快了
那你現在進展太快
我跟你講下一代會更快喔
你要記得他們說的話
監督已經趕不上AI發展的速度了
監督的速度
所以知道這個東西之後
你怎麼會跟我小鼻子小眼睛呢
國巨會不會創新高 遲早會好不好
遲早會 台股有機會再翻一倍
當然我不會說
當然我不要那麼貪心嘛
我先求800就好了 好不好
我認為遲早會
10萬點怎麼可能不會創新高
應該說就算不創新高也不遠
是不是 好不好
精材 我看他一副
就漲到600塊 漲到800塊
這種籌碼感覺1000塊都有可能
你不要覺得1000塊沒有可能
景碩以前推薦的時候都不到100
欣興不到100
南電也是一樣啊
6187萬潤
以前我推薦的時候不到100
現在1300
所以你怎麼會覺得
資本支出概念股
他們就需要台積電嘛
這些股票你怎麼覺得
有機會不到1000元
我知道你會說哲哲 那個不都一樣
LP比雞腿
不好意思 講話比較粗俗
XX比雞腿
不會 需求都會Double以上
Double以上是算少的
你一定要看到我看到的未來
那個辨識很恐怖啊
瞬間辨識很恐怖
是不是 OK嗎
這台會教總經 AI趨勢
還有醫學保健 還會剪指甲
要剪指甲
怎麼辦 不要放大
怎麼辦 我最近太忙了
我指甲長得好快
我只記得剪頭髮 忘記剪指甲
好啦 來
三星發展兩奈米對台積電影響
沒有那麼厲害啦 好不好
兩奈米沒那麼快啦
有CPI推背圖嗎
好啦 我們先還是講一下
現在幾分了
我們快速講一下
摺疊手機我會買
摺疊手機好像只有兩個顏色嘛 對不對
比如說這個Ultra
最新報導是iPhone Duo
有沒有看到
然後這個白色 銀白色
我應該買銀白色
你覺得哪個會賣比較好 深藍嗎
還是白色 銀白色
應該是白色
導播你覺得哪一種 白色
我是問你喔 不是要送你喔
白色
那個呢 我要銀白的
那個呢 導播呢
我也覺得白色會比較好
白色喔 因為太深了
沒看到這個東西對不對
你們覺得這個摺疊機會賣得好嗎
應該賣得不錯
因為第一款嘛 是不是
華為都三摺機了
這個好像不錯
好啦 我會這兩個都買
我會買這個水藍色 加上這一個
加上這個Ultra
看哪個比較好用 PK一下好不好
那我覺得這個會賣得不錯啦
好不好 這個應該賣得不錯
蘋果手機應該有機會上漲 應該有
蘋果的股價應該有機會上漲
可是蘋果不是最AI的
我覺得它
應該遲早會讓出老大的位置
來 怕缺貨沒記憶體
所以記憶體也會再拉
還會再拉啦
記憶體最大問題是漲太多了
所以有一些股票沒有漲很多
或者跌很深的
被動元件我不知道你怕什麼
記得記憶體 被動元件要解套要找我
記憶體要解套要找我
我是記憶體專家 我更是被動專家
被動王子 記得好不好 OK嗎
好 這我跟大家講的
我們再一次這首歌
再唱一下 唱一下
好 唱
愛你越久我越被動
只因你的愛 居無定所
好 就這樣
投資朋友記得一件事好不好
真的啦 被動元件都會噴出去啦
世界先進也有機會
世界先進拉了
我是覺得華新科再一根
我還是 現在只剩兩天嘛
我禮拜一預告了嘛
我說這禮拜國巨有機會噴漲停
再給我兩天
你看我能不能逆轉勝 好不好
國巨我至少明後天
我覺得有機會碰到漲停
我不敢說百分之百
因為碰漲停是壓力滿大的一個預言
當然我覺得有機會喔 好不好
不要說我沒說
還有什麼股票 台積電
你什麼都不知道
你就買台積電 台灣50
反正放一倍嘛
總比放在銀行好
我都已經講那麼赤裸了
你還放在銀行真的傻了
但是風險請自負
不要什麼都怪我 好不好
賺錢沒來謝謝我 賠錢來怪我
這個我不能接受 好不好
來 我們來看一下華邦電
所以現在股票不要追
華邦電直接拉起來又殺下去了 莫名其妙
還是有機會噴出去啦 好不好
對 今天還有個帆宣 有沒有
帆宣噴出第一根
這個量不得了
3000多張 不多啦
但是這個噴出量 技術線型滿漂亮
看明天是不是隔日沖要玩你
所以明天不一定要追
你反而等後天再看看 懂嗎
現在股票就這樣子
那我們看一下 帆宣
恭喜6196帆宣
股價大漲超過6%
創近一個月新高
我們多次買進
最高已經大賺50%
我持續看好它 手上持股獲利續抱
50%了
精材賺150%還沒走 非人哉
然後台勝科今天也拉起來
都是這樣 有沒有
看起來就是要噴出去了
所以你去想想看你要怎樣的分析師
我不去事後話 我不去馬後炮
一切的一切我預告在前面好不好
今天廣達也拉起來了
老AI希望動
老AI最大問題就是要死不活
沒關係 真的慢我們還是可以換股票
好不好 像智原慢我們還是都有考慮
要不要換 我都有在想
可是都是會員權益 好不好
所以你看 股票我都盡量都會解釋
我一定 是盡我最大的誠信
讓你知道什麼叫認真的分析師
不會股票變變變 變不見
股票變變變 天天漲停板你們都相信
我今天花了很大篇幅
這幾天花了很大篇幅告訴你AI
因為真的這幾天
這一個月真的太多AI的變化了
很恐怖 AGI
可以用的東西太多了 太恐怖了
所以這個發展跟需求性太恐怖
重點是最聰明的那一群人
也不知道它會發展到哪邊去
這是最恐怖的一件事情
所以你要能理解我內心的恐懼
台灣股市3年10萬點 我還覺得很簡單
你不要說2年內
我的意思是說
我真的覺得有機會2年內
只是我不想要壓力那麼大
我想比較寬鬆一點
我是告訴你3年內10萬點
那3年10萬點 你的錢
放個1000萬就可以變2000萬
我講的是最保守
放台灣50
我還是要強調一件事 這沒有一定
但是我非常看好後面的行情
我看到是AI的未來 AI的趨勢
我不像其他分析師
每天跟你講那些有的沒有
天天講漲停板
我的績效也很好
但是我花很少時間去講自己的績效
所以你去想想看你要怎樣的分析師
你看 這是我今天第二次稍微講
化被動為主動
每次都講都沒有幾秒鐘
所以化被動為主動
主動88專案
我主動發給你
你被動元件有套牢的要找我
你記憶體有套牢的要找我
主動幫你發簡訊
也希望讓你主動發發發
化被動為主動
主動88專案
歡迎來電洽詢0800668085
或者加我LINE私訊我 好不好
加我的LINE私訊我
不論對或錯哲哲一切的一切預告在前面
你想想看你要怎樣的分析師
也預祝各位能夠賺大錢
AI新時代真的來臨了
你看不清楚這個行情的話
你會少賺一大筆
要相信我 AI時代來臨
也預祝各位能夠賺大錢
Byebye